I'm going to be speaking with David Livingstone
Smith, who's a professor of philosophy at
the University of New England in Maine and
also author of the book on Inhumanity, Dehumanization
and How to Resist That.
I really appreciate your time today.
Thank you, David.
So to set the stage for the conversation,
when we talk about dehumanization and inhumanity,
there are a lot of ways that we could sort
of define those ideas.
But what what do you mean when you talk about
that?
Well, dehumanization is a word that's used
in so many different ways.
I mean, even in the scholarly literature,
what I mean by demonization is the attitude
of conceiving of other people as subhuman
creatures.
And in history, there are so many different
examples of when we can say that this dehumanization
took place.
There are times where it can take place by
people who are trying to justify horrible
acts of violence.
There are times when dehumanization might
even be a coping mechanism by someone exposed
to extremely harsh or difficult conditions
in some way, shape or form.
What are some of the different ways that in
human history this has manifested?
Well, almost always.
Demonization is the product of propaganda.
So it's not something that spontaneously rises
in the human mind.
Rather, it's the result of people in positions
of power who want us to do terrible things
to one another.
And the paradigmatic example of that is, is
genocide.
So if those in power, those who are in positions
of authority, can convince us that these others
that they wish us to harm are dangerous, toxic,
subhuman creatures that we must destroy in
our own self defense, then that allows us
to overcome a very natural resistance.
Human beings have to doing awful things to
one another.
I'm thinking of so many of the books I've
read about the Holocaust and concentration
camps and the way in which concentration camp
guards, SS Nazi soldiers, et cetera, by by
propaganda.
I mean, quite literally, the story that Hitler
was telling about, about Jews and and about
some others was about these people are not
really human the way we are.
But there's also, interestingly, in some of
the memoirs of survivors of concentration
camps, they said they also experienced the
sort of dehumanization even of their peers,
which they saw almost as a survival instinct.
Which which is that a different mechanism?
Well, yes, we'd have to go into some detail
about what they had in mind.
But certainly people who are the victims of
dehumanization are quite aware generally that
they're seen as subhuman creatures.
I mean, we find this in the example of the
Holocaust and the two examples that I use
most of my work are the Holocaust, which,
by the way, has centuries old roots in European
anti-Semitism.
Jews had been dehumanized since the since
the 12th century in Europe and also the brutal
oppression of black people in the United States,
particularly in the aftermath of the American
Civil War.
And in both those instances, the victims of
demonization.
We're well aware that they were seen as subhuman
creatures, monsters, demons, vermin.
As a historical note, what is the is I'm curious
whether you're aware of I know of of antisemitism
based on the idea of Jews bringing the plague.
And I'm I don't remember if that's 13th century
or 14th century.
Is that the earliest example you're aware
of or is there something prior to that?
Well, well, demonization of Jews, we find
it sporadically earlier.
So in the Gospel of John, Jews are described
as offspring of Satan.
Right.
So that's a very early Christian route of
some anti-Semitic ideas.
Right.
So if you're the offspring of Satan, you're
demonic.
Yes.
This idea of the demonic Jew persisted.
But it really took a terrible turn during
the first crusade when Christians marched
off to to the Holy Land to win it back from
the infidel.
And along the way, they decided to attack
the infidel in their midst.
Remember, Jews were the only religious minority
who were permitted to survive in Europe.
Right.
And it's from this point onward that Jews
are racialized.
They're seen as an alien and inferior race
and seen as demonic, devilish, biologically
different, even though it was believed that
Jewish men menstruated, that Jews had horns
and tails and and so on.
And so it just picks up there.
And then after the bubonic plague of the mid
14th century, it gets really, really, really
bad when it comes to the I guess we would
the dehumanizes, so to speak.
Sometimes words or terms like they are monsters,
they are animals, et cetera, are applied,
which is in a sense is the dehumanization
of the dehumanizes.
Is is that a is that something we should be
concerned about doing?
Are the risks of doing that?
Yeah, absolutely.
We should be concerned about that.
Monsters are fictional.
No one is a monster.
Hitler was not a monster, I'm Jewish.
I can say that Hitler was not a monster.
Goebbels was not a monster.
These are human beings.
And it would really benefit us if we considered
them as holding up a mirror to what is possible.
For any human being, you know, we are all
vulnerable.
There is no vaccination against humanizing
attitudes.
Is it is the term dehumanization relevant
to I'm thinking back a few months now during
the coronavirus pandemic, the lieutenant governor
of Texas, Dan Patrick, gave this viral interview,
I think it was on Fox News where he said something
about, listen, I would be willing to sacrifice
myself, I think grandma or so to speak, something
like that.
They're willing to sacrifice themselves for
the good of the economy by which he really
meant the stock market.
Is that a sort of dehumanization that we've
seen during coronavirus of when you see a
number, 4000 died or 3000 died and you just
sat in your house and worked from home?
It doesn't really feel that that difference
of a thousand, you don't feel it in any real
way.
It seems like that's a form of dehumanization.
Some some people would call it demonization.
I prefer a very fine grained notion of what
do you immunization is.
So there are a bunch of related attitudes.
But you see, I think if we're to understand
what I consider the most toxic form of these
attitudes, which I reserve the term demonization
for, we need to get a good understanding of
how it works.
Otherwise we don't have a chance in hell of
dismantling it.
Right.
So I would call that callousness.
And of course, what he's saying, in fact,
is he's willing to sacrifice the lives, the
life of grandma.
Right.
Grandma and speaking their.
Are are there things you've observed during
the pandemic that you would apply the term
dehumanization to?
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
So what's gone on in this pandemic, as is
typical, by the way, of earlier pandemics,
is xenophobia.
So the pandemic is blamed on others, racial
others.
Race and humanization are very closely tied
together.
And then when you start talking about people
as disease, as dangerous outsiders, you are
either well on the way towards humanization
or actually there.
You see, it's it's not regarded as especially
acceptable to call people demons and monsters
anymore.
So we have substitute terms.
They're diseased, they're criminal, they're
dangerous, they're bad to the bone.
And what we get in this pandemic and in previous
pandemics is an upsurge in that kind of feeling,
which has historically led to all sorts of
horrible things.
It seems as though dehumanizing the rhetoric
of dehumanization probably has some specific
overlap with authoritarian regimes and authoritarian
ism.
Is it can we can you talk about that a little
bit?
Yeah, sure.
So there are two ways that I think the first
question to to address is why do immunization
in the first place?
And the reason, I believe, is that human beings
being highly social animals have difficulty.
Performing acts of lethal or even sublethal
violence in one another, we're just equipped
with these inhibitions.
But those are very inconvenient if you want
to oppress and exterminate others.
So.
As I said, people in positions of power of
authority can tell us, you know, these others,
they might look like you and me, they might
look like human beings.
But really deep down, where it counts on the
inside, they're something else.
And that is absolutely typical of authoritarian
going on fascist.
It seems almost like a tool that's necessary
for such a regime to advance its its propaganda
tool.
And you talked about the role of propaganda
and dehumanization early.
It seems that for for authoritarian regimes
that dehumanization of the others is necessary
for them to advance their goals.
It's certainly extremely helpful.
I would say may maybe near necessary.
I hesitate to say anything is necessary, but
it is certainly it is certainly helpful.
Sometimes the dehumanizing ideology is distributed
through a community.
So I as I say, in the first chapter of Honored
Humanity, I grew up in the Deep South in the
50s and 60s and there dehumanizing attitudes
towards black people.
They were that was in the air.
You breathe, you need a Rush Limbaugh say
to propagate these things.
What how casual was the dehumanization when
you were growing up in the South?
Oh, it was just it just as you know, we would
say the sky is up and the earth is down.
Black people who were not referred to by that
word, sure, the winner were seen as filthy.
Subhuman animals, I mean, that was kids in
my high school would brag about hunting black
kids with their B.B. guns on weekends for
sport.
Hmm.
That's that's and do you was the was there
a gradual transition out of that that aligned
with the civil rights era 1964 Civil Rights
Act, did it lag that it was a gradual transition,
but also retrenchment?
I mean, these things have not gone away.
Still, we like to think about the new south.
But these are these things take a very, very,
very long time to change.
They do not disappear quickly.
They can remain latent, relatively invisible.
For a long period of time, and then the social
environment changes a little bit.
Someone in power like our former president
gives permission for certain kinds of attitudes
and bang, you know, the Confederate flags
are out.
What where where do things like eugenics and
phrenology play into this, because on the
one hand, you know, stuff about measuring
skull ratios and all this stuff, it in a sense,
it's very human in that we're looking at the
minutia of of the characteristics of the human
form.
But it's its use seems to be dehumanizing.
Well, it's actually a bit worse than that.
So if we look at the history of scientific
racism in the United States.
Yeah.
During the period when these practices were
beginning to flourish, eugenics is a bit later.
But certainly the skull measurement work.
The premier scientific authorities in the
country described black people as literally
another species.
They were learned papers on this and mixed
race.
People were seen as literally as hybrids between
different species.
So these see you see, they're the dehumanizing
attitude is endorsed by scientific authority.
It could be scientific authority.
It could be political or it's anyone who has
that kind of influence, right?
Yeah.
I mean, that that makes and I know you write
about this in the book.
It brings me to the topic of climate change
and climate science.
What do you say maybe to the audience?
It's not obvious the connection between dehumanization,
the way we've talked about in authoritarian
regimes and so on, and the connection to climate
change.
Yeah, well, the the aspect of climate change
that's most salient for me and my work on
the organization is that I think catastrophic
climate change, which I don't think anyone's
going to do anything about.
I think we're well, too late for that.
And there's insufficient motivation, despite
the fine words that are said is going to create
a situation which is a perfect storm for really
dangerous forms of demonization.
There will be refugee problems like the world
has never known, you know, when when the population
of Bangladesh spills into India.
And resources run short and infrastructures
break down.
This is going to generate intense xenophobia
and I would put good money on demonizing rhetoric
of the worst, most genocidal sort is the only
way to prevent it to prevent the climate refugees
from becoming refugees.
I mean, is there is if that happens, is there
really any way to prevent what you're describing?
I'd like to know and I'd like to I'd like
to think that there is yeah, we're human beings.
We can we can change our behavior, but we
have to know about it.
We have to be aware of it.
We have to be vigilant and there have to be
policies in place to help us.
And I just don't think we're awake enough
to the possibilities to take the sorts of
steps which will be necessary.
That's one reason I wrote the book.
Demonization is an ongoing problem and.
To do something about it, we have to understand
it, we have to understand how it works, why
we are all vulnerable to humanizing propaganda
and what steps we might be able to take to
at least constrain it.
The book is on inhumanity, dehumanization
and how to resist it.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Professor David Livingstone Smith.
An important topic.
And I appreciate you joining me to talk about
it today.
I appreciate you inviting The David Pakman
Show and David Pakman Dutkiewicz.